a big theme of this season is questions
about you two having a baby so where are
we at on the baby brat or baby judy
journey is there a timeline so i will
we'll say this we
when we started to discuss this we
didn't realize um
how many different hurdles can kind of
come in a way we're excited we are
where we are we'll give that we are very
excited where we stand as of today but
there just has been quite a few hurdles
that we have not been open with social
media or anybody about yeah for health
reasons oh yeah
but we are excited yeah and a lot of
that's covered in the season yeah
there was an instagram post at the end
of january right where you guys said we
are extending the family was that more
generic and letting people know look we
in the future we can't wait to be
parents and and extend our family like
do you want to kind of clear up the
instagram posts
that happened in real time on the show
so
you'd have to kind of watch the show to
see
exactly where that stem from the purpose
of it would have led to
where we are on our journey
do you take this woman to be your wedded
wife i do i do i do i do
[Applause]
now we gonna have a baby because season
two of rat loves judy i'm so excited
y'all especially because we're gonna get
a little more inside behind the scenes
look at planning the wedding of the
century which i'm really excited about
but for you two how does it feel to
share that special day with the world it
feels good i mean
it was a rough day
you know i thought because it's such a
wondrous and glorious day and marvelous
and beautiful and all these
fantasy things that it would be easy uh
uh it wasn't so easy like a lot of
things went left
oh my god the four days from the wedding
we just need to pause for a minute we
always think i'm challenging i'm not
challenging you are we doing it are we
not i don't know
and
people
yeah people got fussed out and
people weren't doing what they were
supposed to do they weren't where they
were supposed to be
and it puts the stress on the people who
are getting married so
it is like really so it turned out to be
a beautiful wedding we kind of at the
wedding we kind of tuned everything and
everybody out but a lot went on to get
to that point and the stresses of
getting the wedding together before that
there's a lot of that too because we did
wait to the last minute yeah and uh yeah
that was philadelphia in like nine days
yeah the wedding is because she's
working so long because she's blaming
everything on me when you guys are
sharing it on a reality show is it hard
to relive it or can you watch it back
and now maybe laugh a little bit at all
that you went through when we watch it
back i mean when i cry and stuff on tv i
cringe because i grew up knowing and
believing that crying shows like
weakness and vulnerability and when they
see you sweat they know when your
breaking point is so when i watch the
show back that makes me cringe but i
feel like when we watch it we do have
some things that we laugh at and we
learn from and we see things like oh my
god i don't want to ever do that again
so it's a learning experience it's a
laughing experience it's an overall
bonding experience for us what we can
expect from season two there are hints
of you two kind of questioning if you
even would make it to i do you know was
there a moment for either of you where
you questioned if this was the right
choice
i don't think it was questioning if it
was the right choice i think maybe
questioning if it was the right time
because yeah
that there was a date that i put out
there in the earth and she got a tattoo
on her back because because when you
explain how important the date was and
how significant it was to us to our
relationship to everything to you to me
it was on a tuesday it was 2 22 22
right
it's never going to happen again we're
twin flames too
so i mean
i had to make that date happen that that
was that was what was kind of
the biggest question yeah because then
it was you know it's [ __ ] i got this
tattoo on my back you know the clock was
working against us but i did tell her i
did tell her if we didn't make that date
we could have done something very
special on that date we didn't have to
get married on that date just because it
was tattooed on my back we there's so
many other special things in life that
we could do together to commemorate that
day that we could have gotten married
later she said uh-uh i'm keeping that
day i want that day
and my husband
and now you have that date forever
though you know it's yours it's yours
yeah right you're right
so how is newlywed life treating y'all
you still in the honeymoon phase
i think so yes i think so
i think but i think we started the
honeymoon phase before
[Laughter]
what would you say is the biggest lesson
you've learned in being wife and wife so
far you're so beautiful no pleasure
quite a few
you answered this one what do you think
your biggest lesson is
my biggest lesson is um being patient
and learning how that when my wife is
working
how to
take my ass somewhere else and get some
work done too because eventually when
she stops then i'll go lay beside her
and we'll go spend our time together
before i used to get very upset like put
the damn phone down you are not married
to the phone you are married to me i am
human the phone is not flash the phone
can't kiss you like i can
you know but i've i've gotten some
patience and and and i'm getting better
at it each day yeah
judy so uh in in the reverse
i've learned well what what i've done
since being married and actually a lot
of my um my staff has to bring this to
my attention i've put i've committed a
lot of time to put people and structure
in place to where i do not have to be as
hands-on so the plan is to set up the
company to where once it's
once it's time to dive all the way into
motherhood that we that i can step away
if needed and i can fully focus on us
our relationship you know the growing of
our family i'm going to be very hands-on
yeah
of course
she's not going to let nobody she has
already said nobody can hold a baby i'm
like
yeah you can't
have the people people people visit like
they can wash their hands no but you
can't breathe on my baby see would you
ever
i don't want your lips on my baby
feet i told you those keys and all that
stuff that is for us okay
you're not going to have a sip and see i
think it's cute but i think she's only
if we have something like that she's not
she's not going to let everybody near
her baby right
right yes i will if we have something
like she's gonna have it cutely broke
off or something
to take your pictures
so uh this season we also get a look
inside of your creative process with new
music um what's it like yes what's it
like to let cameras into that sacred
sacred studio space oh man that's
awesome that's that's my judge you know
that's what i do that's what i have a
passion for so i don't mind at all
letting cameras in for that i love the
creative process of writing music
producing music coming up with melodies
and harmonies and stuff like that is
what i love to do i'm dropping a new
song it's called tick tock with hero the
band i'm finishing up the whole project
and it's going to be amazing uh listen
you know we we see in the premiere brat
you praising judy for giving you the
courage to come out i mean judy what
does that mean to you when you hear that
and you feel that i like it it's a
little bit of a wait though cause we've
had so many conversations about
well around it and about it before it
happened i just wanted to make sure that
she was only doing this
for her personal reasons she just kept
saying because i love you i'm like it
has to be for your personal reasons now
since then i'll stay since she's been
living out loud and loving the fact that
she can do what she wants what she wants
because before you know she wouldn't
hold hands in public or nothing but now
she just give a give
brad you've inspired so many people with
your journey the two of you have
inspired so many people with your love
and with june being lgbtq pride month i
am curious like what does this month
mean to you guys and have your like
views and thoughts of what pride is
evolved like what does pride mean to you
now
i
i think for me
i i think i'm i'm glad we have a month
but for me i think i've looked at humans
as human beings for so long that
sometimes i have to tap into
or really kind of i hate to say but come
back down to earth to be able to
understand because i feel like no matter
what your sexuality is no matter how you
identify you still should have the same
rights you still should be treated
equally so for me i i think that's a
mindset that i've had for so long
that it's when it comes to this it's
like oh because i i go straight into oh
people are not marketing you know what
i'm saying people are not marketing
people are now trying to leverage
something to market and i think about
the fact that what happens the month
before the month after and all we're all
human
if just because i fell in love with a
woman doesn't make me less than it
doesn't it it shouldn't take any rights
away so i i feel like when it comes to
prime money i'm happy we have one
but i think i honestly think it should
be all year long amen brad do you share
that sentiment what are your thoughts
yes that was so amazing i shared that
sentiment i'm so happy to be free it is
such a different feeling yes living for
yourself and in your truth and being who
you are opposed to trying to hide it for
a record label or so you know lose your
career or so you know you know you can't
tell people who you like or who you love
like i'm so happy that she
the courage like i was just watching her
live out loud like i want to live out
loud too you know what i'm saying like
so it just it's like a weight lifted for
real and it just it's the best feeling
and i wish everybody could feel the way
i do and i wish people could just like
let it go already let us be free let us
love who we love like if the world could
be happy with who they love it might be
a safer place you know
[Music]
you